absence doesn't always make the heart
grow fonder from The Not So Fantastic
Four to a man who should have stayed on
Mars these long-awaited movies probably
should have stayed in development hell
if there's one superhero team that's had
a tough time at the box office it's the
Fantastic Four the iconic superhero
family has been repeatedly put on film
for no other reason than to prevent the
film rights from lapsing and that's
resulted in several lackluster
adaptations the first shot in 1994 and
never released is notoriously awful and
was only made so that producer burnt
eichinger could hold on to the film
rights
bird
s rights eventually landed at 20th
Century Fox which produced Fantastic
Four in 2005 and Fantastic Four Rise of
the Silver Surfer in 2007. both were box
office successes but never garnered much
of a following in 2015 Fox released
another new Fantastic Four reboot but it
wasn't easy to make plans for the
rebirth franchise began in 2009 but the
movie got stuck in development hell for
six years by 2012 director Josh trank
had signed on leading to scripture
rights should wouldn't begin until 2014.
the film was finally released to
overwhelmingly negative reviews critics
said that it was devoid of any humor and
featured completely unlikable characters
while the actors did their best with the
script they were given very little of it
related to the classic Source material
leaving comic book fans feeling betrayed
Disney's acquisition of fox in 2019 has
resulted in another planned reboot
within the celebrated MCU so there may
be brighter days ahead
1984 is Beverly Hills Cop was a massive
success for Eddie Murphy earning a hit
sequel in 1987 which made 10 times its
budget at the box office fans expected
another movie to follow but Murphy was
opposed to it telling Rolling Stone in
1989 that there was no reason to do it
at the time a script was in development
and the film was in pre-production
despite the star's apprehension thinking
they had a good thing anyhow the studio
persevered and Beverly Hills Cop 3 was
eventually made over the course of seven
years the script went through numerous
drafts and included various ideas that
never made it into the film producers
Don Simpson and Jerry Bruckheimer left
over budget constraints as Paramount cut
costs the duo also balked at an
unrealistic production schedule which
limited their ability to make the movie
they had in mind Paramount eventually
came to terms with the costs Murphy had
a 15 million dollar price tag and a
budget initially thought to be 55
million dollars continued to rise
eventually the studio finished the
project in Beverly Hills Cop 3 was
released to a weak box office the film
made a fraction of its predecessors and
it's widely regarded as the worst in the
franchise
despite this a fourth film went into
development in the late 90s moved from
Paramount Pictures to Netflix in 2019
and was filmed last year with the
release date yet to be announced the
X-Files was a stellar success throughout
its TV run in the 90s and early 2000s it
was successful enough that it expanded
into a feature film in 1998 while the
series was still airing new episodes the
film did well at the box office and sat
snugly between two episodes at the end
Fifth Season seeing as the first film
did well it's not surprising that the
studio began development of a sequel in
2001. the plan was to release it after
the ninth season concluded sometime in
2003 or 2004. that didn't happen and
production stalled as everyone involved
needed to find the time to make it
happen eventually the movie began
production of principal Photography in
2007. six years after the studio began
working on it filming wrapped the
following year and the X-Files I want to
believe managed to claw its way out of
development hell with the summer 2008
release unfortunately the movie didn't
do as well as its predecessor unlike the
first film I want to believe didn't move
the overall storyline Along the movie
ended up being a standalone tale
amounting to more of a monster of the
week five than adding to the overall
Narrative of the series it received in
different reviews from critics and
didn't perform as well as expected at
the box office I want to believe made
only 68 million dollars falling far
short of the Studio's goals David brins
the postman was published in 1985. in
Warner Brothers quickly optioned the
rights for a big screen adaptation later
when the author's wife joined him to
attend a screening a Field of Dreams she
immediately saw Kevin Costner in the
lead role that hope was realized 10
years later when Warner Brothers began
production Costner immediately chucked
the first script in the bin and got to
work on another Costner was also tapped
to direct and seeing as he'd directed
Dances with Wolves and took home three
Academy Awards for his effort double
dipping with him was a no-brainer this
gave Costner far more creative control
than he would have had as just an actor
the film was screened to test audiences
who absolutely hated it but Warner
Brothers couldn't convince Costner to
edit it down from its 177 minute run
time refusing to take the test
screenings results into account results
in an a poorly received movie that spent
a decade in development hell gruelingly
paced and load by critics the film only
made 20.8 million dollars against a
budget of 80 million earn Costner one of
the worst Financial failures of his
career
Stephen King spent three decades riding
The Dark Tower series eventually
publishing nine books and building a
huge fan base around his Dark Fantasy
Saga development of a screened version
began in 2007 with JJ Abrams on board
having optioned the rights from King
directly for nineteen dollars a number
that holds significance within the
series by 2010 Abrams was out and
director Ron Howard stepped in he'd also
leave though he remained as a producer
in 2015 Sony Pictures nabbed the rights
and tap Nikolai arcel to direct filming
began in 2016 and after several delays
it was finally released in mid-2017
after 10 years in development the film's
reception suggested it should have
remained there as critics decided that
the final product was incredibly
disappointing saying that the Dark Tower
is almost entirely unfaithful to the
books that inspired it plans to release
a sequel were abandoned and a television
version was picked up and then dropped
by Amazon the film effectively killed
its own franchise leading minito hope
for a new adaptation somewhere down the
line
The Lone Ranger entered popular culture
as a radio show in the 1930s which was
followed by a television series that ran
from 1949 to 1957. the character would
go on to inspire Comics novels video
games and a cartoon the franchise didn't
expand to include a feature film until
the 21st century long after the
character's popularity diminished
regardless Colombia pictures began
development in 2002. though the project
would soon find its way into a
development nightmare six years after
pre-production began Johnny Depp was
cast to play Tonto though concerns over
the film's budget remained it would be
several years before Army Hammer was
tapped to play the lead filming began in
2012 and ran into delays but the Lone
Ranger finally emerged after 11 years in
June 2013 and it didn't take long for
criticisms to pile up could be worse
worse
how could this be worse much concern
came over casting depth to play a Native
American character though that was only
one of many problems another criticism
of the film was its Pace with plenty of
critics calling it boring The Lone
Ranger was a box office bomb the alien
and Predator franchises were always
popular among fans but matching the two
together didn't enter popular culture
until 1990. that's when Dark Horse
Comics released Aliens vs Predator as a
crossover short story the concept proved
popular and the following year Peter
Briggs wrote a spec screenplay based on
the comics but the studio shelved it
instead 20th Century Fox developed
multiple video games alien Predator
sci-fi's baddest boys together at last
with a little time to kill the studio
finally began pre-production of the
actual film in 2002. briggs's script was
scrapped in favor of setting the movie
on earth and the movie hit theaters in
August 2004. 13 years after development
began the film ended up tapping into the
concept created in the comics but missed
the mark in numerous ways while Alien vs
Predator has its fans many found the
movie dull saying that the film lacked
the horror element the alien franchise
requires and many of the characters were
uninspired despite this the film was a
financial success garnering a sequel
that was better left unmade the general
consensus is that it's far worse than
its predecessor even though it also made
a tidy sum at the box office
Green Lantern has been around in one
form or another since 1940 but the
characters popularity really exploded in
the 1990s like other DC Comics
characters the Green Lantern has shown
up in various media over the years
including video games animated films and
TV series the development of a big
screen live-action adaptation didn't
begin until 1997. Kevin Smith and
Quentin Tarantino were approached about
making the movie but both declined
scripts were written and discarded as
development continued over the course of
several years Warner Brothers invested
200 million dollars into the project and
filming finally began in 2010 with
Martin Campbell directing after some
production delays the movie also
required a lot of CGI delaying their
release and messing up the film's
marketing campaign causing further
problems Green Lantern hit theaters in
2011 14 years after development began
the film failed at the box office and
killed the studios as plans to use it to
launch a DC film Universe the movies
over Reliance on CGI turned off many
viewers including its star Ryan Reynolds
and please don't make the super suit
green
or animated
Japanese fans first met Speed Racer in
manga form in 1966 and the following
year the character was adapted into a 52
episode anime series the series aired
almost concurrently in Japan and the
United States and was incredibly popular
in 1992 Warner Brothers began developing
a live-action film adaptation but the
project ran into casting and script
issues over the next few years and
stalled the wachowskis joined the
project in 2006 and Speed Racer entered
pre-production filming commenced in 2007
and the movie finally hit theaters in
2008 escaping development hell after 16
years Warner Brothers launched a massive
marketing campaign hoping to cover the
budget of 120 million dollars but
unfortunately Speed Racer failed at the
box office making only about 94 million
dollars according to the Los Angeles
Times Warner Brothers was in for
Combined production and marketing cost
of 250 million dollars so the studio
lost a ton of cash despite Speed Racer
failing at the box office it eventually
acquired a sizable fan base these days
it's considered a cult classic though
many outside the fandom can't overcome
the movie's Reliance on the mistargeted
demographic which many critics suggested
lay firmly with 12 year old boys
the original Space Jam was an incredible
success and the film quickly built a
massive following almost immediately
after its release in 1996 talk started
about making a sequel development began
and the film was set to feature Michael
Jordan taking part in a new competition
when it became clear that Jordan wasn't
interested Warner Brothers shut down
production just as it was getting off
the ground it would take decades before
the studio would bring the project to
fruition work continued sporadically
throughout the 2000s and in 2014 Warner
Brothers announced that LeBron James was
attached despite the progress the movie
wouldn't begin filming until 2019
because Space Jam a new Legacy required
a great deal of Animation
post-production took some time and the
film was finally released in July 2021
25 years after development began
a new Legacy hit theaters with a lot of
expectations and for many it failed to
deliver Alex Shepard of the new Republic
rope it is a film that has no reason to
exist except as a vehicle for reminding
people that various pieces of content
all of them merchandisable are available
for instant streaming now despite this
audience has enjoyed the movie for its
Nostalgia and overall entertainment
value
Edgar Rice Burroughs is a Princess of
Mars was published in 1912 and became a
quintessential piece of American Pulp
Fiction making John Carter a pop culture
icon development of an animated
adaptation began in 1932 and by 1935 MGM
had test footage completed before the
studio decided to abandon It Disney got
into the John Carter adaptation game in
the 50s but this effort also faltered
Marvel even adapted John Carter into
comics in the 70s it looked as if
adapting a Princess of Mars was
impossible decades passed and eventually
Disney gave the green light to a modern
adaptation hoping it would result in a
Trilogy filming began in 2010 and after
post-production and reshoots John Carter
finally graced the Silver Screen 81
years after development began the movie
dropped both the concepts of princesses
and Mars from the title so as not to
alienate specific viewers instead they
found almost no one Disney went all out
with special effects and marketing
spending over 263 million dollars to
make the movie which earned just 282.7
million dollars worldwide John Carter
was a historic blot proving that
adapting a story a century after it was
first published can be pretty difficult
foreign